abone ol
e
[Alkış]
herkese merhaba ben davulcu kimi
televizyonlardan video Belki ikimiz
dijital projelerinden bilmiyorum içinden
çık sportstream mutluluk içi onlar oldu
Aslında genelde enerjim çok güzel derler
bana ve bu enerji
sanırım kumaş kullandım ve insanların
halk edici şeyler yazmaya çalıştım
onlardan biri
bir üniversite hayatının başında bizim
ailecek maddedir muz çok çok giren bir
süreç yaşadık ve
süzülerek anlatmam gereken bir hikaye
olabilecek en çok güzel bir kenetlenme
yaşadık birbirimizi çok güzel destek
oldu mu
[Alkış]
Allah Allah veriyor
yani
istiyorum çünkü bu aşağıdan sordum ne
olmak istiyorsun dünya gezmek istiyorum
diyordum yeni insanlarla tanışmak
istiyorum Duydum bu insanları nasıl
ulaşabilirim ulaşabilirim dünyada
Diplomat olarak gezebilirim diyordu
Bu soruya cevap vermek için çok küçük
olduğunu fark ettim tam şey bu emin
değilim aslında o
o ve birçoğu Size bıraktım part-time
çalışabilirim çünkü okula devam etmem
gerekiyordu hiçbir kabul etmedi
görüşürüz seven hepside bir yerlerde
önceden tercih edilmesi gerektiğini
söyledi
hakikat
yılmadan Çünkü babama karşıdan geldi
çalışacağım dedim o iş bulamazsın dedi
ve bulabileceğimiz patlamam gerekir
Ankara'da yaşıyorum ben orada olduğumda
ya
[Müzik]
ne
soruyorlar bana benden Bizimki vereceğim
Bir ara aşkım geri gitti
güzel konuşuyorsun dedi o zaman abi
pastanenin önünde insanları karşılayan
bir görevli henüz başlamamıştı biz böyle
bir şey olsun okey dedim başladı orada
işe burada herkes arasında makinesi
girmiş i3m çalışabilir 5 çalışabilir
yemez diye
bir ay başladı fakat hiç
bir hiç hayatım ne demek orada görüyorum
bir Anladım hayatım devam ediyor Yani
her gün bırakmam gerektiğini yorulduğunu
söylüyor bu oyuncu biliyoruz bu insanlar
ve
özellikle
enerji çok güzel cümlesini mı
O çok yoğun cayıt Hadi şimdi oyunculuk
diz ediyorum Neden olmasın
oyuncu olur bu ya işte bir Hadi gel bir
oyunculuk değil olsun
var mı
O da zaman hiçbir şey yok nasıl olacağım
beni bir daha ben şimdi sıra başladım
gittim televizyon kanalında
başladım o
[Müzik]
o bile okulla ilgili O zaman bana dedi
ki yerlerin hiç bir de böyle kolay işlem
olmayacağı için sadece dediler
bunu yapmam lazım
televizyon kanalı çağıracak diye
bekliyorum Bekliyorum yok iki ay
Televizyona mı
O
öyle böyle derken ki daha biri
ısrarından dolayı poposundan gibi Tamam
enerji güzel yani bakalım de 1 başla 2
ay boyunca satacaktım iki ayda artık
staj yapma Süresi doldu maalesef yani
kanallar bir süre sonra tutamayacağım de
ve 1 başla kanala ilk işe başlayacağım
kanala ve onları oldu
başladım sonrasında insanların
karşılıklı yere konuşmanın ne demek
olduğunu öğrendim yani gazeteci
televizyonda bir dakika izlediğiniz
önemli olan o
[Müzik]
bu şahit olan insanlar oldu
birçok Bayramdan sonra Hayatımda çok
büyük Onlar bıraksa benim o başında
istediğim Diplomat olursan çok insan
tanıyorum hikayemdeki insanlar oldu
kapıyı bir şey yapmam lazımdı bu
insanların Sesini Duyurma onun fayda
sağlamaya hazırsak Bu hayatta bir dönem
sağlık maviyken pek çok çocuğun tedavisi
için imkanlar yarattık mesele çok Gönül
Verdim bu senin çocuğun hayatı için
onlarca haber yazdık ve seslerini
duyurabilmek
haber sonrası çalan telefonlara bakmak
bir çok iyi canlandırıyordu bir şehir
başardığım hissediyorum ve daha fazlası
olmalıdır sonrasında oldu buralarda
operasyonu gittik yediğim operasyonlarda
narkotik şubeden kaçakçılar bir ciddi ve
basma yaz boş bu sırasını diye bir kaç
saniye izlediğiniz haberlerin arka
planında heyecan var ki şu an kendimi
anlatmakta kuruş onlar dediğim
söylüyorsun Peki haber yaptım Onun
içinde yaşadığımız duyguları Anladım ilk
doluyor belki de o yüzden yaşadığım
almayı daha arttırıyorum çok zorlu
bundan sonra haberleri izlerken dedi
biraz da bu gözleri anlatan kişiyi
bakarsınız
yıllarda çıkmış olan ailelerin
çocuklarını gördüğüm zaman çok üzüldüm
çünkü onları Kurtarmak gerekiyordu
aileler o
bu
getireceğim şey kalmadı hissettiğinde
Sivasspor geçirelim günlerce aylarca Ben
çalışıyor çünkü hiçbir
yıllardır bu
AK Parti göster Demirler İyi ki
dönecekler Çünkü onların her zaman bir
oldu bilmiyorum ki öncelikli olarak
Tamam gerekleri kablo sesi
bir kedi sahiplendim tek başına ilk defa
yaşayacaktım
32 yıl ailemle yaşamıştım Ankara gibi
bir yerden sutlar Sofrası diye anılan
İstanbul'a gidecektim Bütün eşyalar için
ailem aldığı İstanbul'a nakliye aracının
verdik babamın biri olarak sayılı ve
kedim Mars'a erkek çalım sosyal medyada
görüyordur
kutusu sizinle birlik ve ben o
filmlerdeki gibi elimde iyi maaşlı
beraber İstanbul'a geldim seni yiyeceğim
İstanbul diyerek çok zorlandım Çünkü o
bilmediğin dünyada
onlarca yarışına Bu gerçekten Kurtlar
Sofrası ydı Kendimi nasıl satmam lazım
da farklı Ne yapmam lazımdı benim bir
geçiş ya da habercilik diğer spor
spikerlerinden suçlarından farklı bir
şeyler biliyorum ve burun nasıl
kullanabilirim derece Benim amacım
çocukların hayatlarını hiçbir şey
yerleştirmek de onlara dokunmak sıvı O
zaman burada yapabilirim sporla beraber
çok şey değiştirebileceğim diyoruz Nasıl
Kore filmi var
çalışanlarına boş oynama üzerine
yetiştiriyor onlara teşekkür ediyor boş
Konyaspor çalışanlar Hani haddinden daha
diye sorma olduğunda en iyi oturmalar
hazırlıyorlar en iyi yarışmacılardan
misin bu soruları yakışıklılar ne demek
Siz Eğer bir videoyla Bir işadamıyla
görüşmek istersiniz size ki Dakikasını
bile ayırmaz kapat boşluğun
turnuvalarına çok sayıda işadamı katıldı
Eğer siz boş ve başarılı olsanız o
adamlarla en az beş saat Oturma da bir
bilirsiniz böyle
dışında
yaşam Hem
daha iyi olur ama
[Müzik]
bu iş adamları nasıl olarak bu
insanlarla Bahar ulaşabilme mi Bence
alıyorsak birçok insanın sağlar dedim ve
tüm spor başındaki gençler Ee
ulaşabilmeyi sağladı markaları tek tek
ulaştım teknik anlattım hepside birlikte
bu projeler ile gençlik ulaştığı
sevdiğine bir kişi bile ulaşsam çok şey
değiştirebileceğimiz söyledim oldu Geldi
mi bir yılında ülkede paneli patladı
Evet şimdi çok iyi yok de tamam
geliyorum zaten başlayan annem ile
birlikte
gelmiş İnsan dünyada Bu nasıl oldu
televizyon kim almaya başladık spor
müsabakaları burada hiçbir şey anlatır
gösteremiyoruz Tabii gelmişim
yapabilirim
dijital baş kahramanlarından biri son
dönemlerde yine televizyon olduğu gibi
hiç tanımıyorum
mesaj atayım mı de gördüm ya da bir
şeylerin falan acı mesaj attım dedim ki
benim bir dijital vuracağım var ve
sporculara örnek olalım sizinle spor
Duygularınızı anlatabilir Ne kadar ünlü
popüler isim varsa ilgilen 10
anlatırlarsa insanlara teşvik olur bu
işe Yani
geçiyor bazen Tamam dedim bir ilk
videomu İşte o zaman Instagram'da
bulacağım başlayacaktı açıldı beraber
yaptım ve sonrasında onlarca
konuk olduğu programlar ama hepsi
programı başladı mı
bu Ucun yaşı hikayemi gördüğüm genç
çocukların ödülü Almanları birçoğu
etkinlik yeniydi güzel tekrar
olabiliyordu Ama bu
yaşadığı şehir
başarabilirsiniz hikayelerini
anlatacağım
zaten yapabileceğimiz şeyler mi
oldu onlar olmasa olmazdı sizinle her
zaman güvendiğiniz bir olsun bu
hikayenin düzenli hep olacak dinlenmesi
diyeceksiniz ama ben çok geç görüştüm
sporda geçti çok daha erken olsaydı
hayatım çok değiştirdi
yaşam döndüm değiştirdi daha dinamik
olmaya başladım enerji yükseldi ve
sizlerden de kesinlikle bir spor
başlangıcımız ayırım kuvvetiniz
istiyorum Benim hop mesleğinde içinizi
burada artı cekmeyince şehir spor hikaye
olacak Çok mutlu oldum meyvenin FIFA
aldım bir hayat olduğu bilgisine Umarım
Sizlerde
hayatımızın dediğinizi ne olduğunu
keşfedebilirsiniz çok sevdiğiniz var
dünyada mm var biri doğduğunuz gün
diğeri neden olduğunuzu farkettiğiniz
gibi diye
Sizlerde kendi aşımızı bulursunuz Buyrun
bir gün yeniden karşılaşırız çok abone
ol